this week we're talking about managing
GCP costs Maps best practices and memory
optimized instances for SA P I'm mark
and welcome to this week in cloud where
we serve you the lowest latency news if
you manage Google cloud costs you'll
want to make sure you check out the new
quick laps quest understanding your gzb
costs with instructional videos and
hands-on labs it's a great way to learn
the fundamentals and try out the GCP
tools you can use to understand
visualize and manage your costs you can
even use the code 1q cost six to six to
go through the labs for free users
expect applications using maps to be
quick and responsive that's why I Travis
is here to share some tips on optimizing
your Google Maps platform applications
with these best practices you can build
your app for scale plus there's even
more tips in the video link if you run
any kind of internet service you know
that production incidents happen the SRA
philosophy is all about minimizing the
impact of incidents while also making
sure they're a learning event see the
details of how a production incident
happens and learn about some tools to
help lower the number of incidents with
this guide you can now deploy workloads
that require up to 12 terabytes of
memory in a single instance on Google
compute engine
these huge instances are certified by sa
p4 Hana and can make sure that you have
the room you need to scale see more
about the details and then try them out
for yourself if you want to read more
about these announcements or see a full
list check out the link have any
thoughts or ideas leave us a comment or
tweet us we'll see you in the collab
you